>> THE UKRAINIAN INTERIOR
MINISTRY IS AMONGST THE VICTIMS
OF A HELICOPTER CRASH THAT
KILLED AT LEAST 17 PEOPLE IN
THE SUBURB OF THE UKRAINIAN
CAPITAL, KYIV.
THE HELICOPTER WAS TRAVELING TO
THE KHARKIV REGION WHEN IT
CRASHED NEAR A KINDERGARDEN IN
THE SUBURB OF BROVARY.
UKRAINE'S PRESIDENTIAL OFFICE
SAYS THAT EIGHT OF THE VICTIMS
WERE LOCAL RESIDENTS, INCLUDING
FOUR CHILDREN.
PRESIDENT VOLODYMYR ZELENSKYY
CONFIRMED THE INTERIOR MINISTER
WAS KILLED IN THE CRASH, ALONG
WITH THE DEPUTY INTERIOR
MINISTER AND OTHER MINISTRY
OFFICIALS.
LET'S BRING IN CNN CHIEF AND
SPECIAL CORRESPONDENT CLARISSA
WARD WHO GOT THEIR VERY QUICKLY,
INDEED.
HOW DID YOU READ THE SITUATION,
CLARISSA?
>> WELL, IT IS UNBELIEVABLY
TRAGIC FOR A COUNTRY, OBVIOUSLY,
MAX, THAT IS ALREADY BEEN
THROUGH SO MUCH IN THIS LAST
YEAR.
YOU CAN SEE THAT I AM STANDING
NOW RIGHT IN FRONT OF THAT
KINDERGARTEN.
IT REALLY TOOK A DIRECT HIT.
WHEN THAT HELICOPTER, ACCORDING
TO EYEWITNESSES CAME FLYING, IT
APPEARED TO LOSE CONTROL OVER
HERE, CLIPPED THE EDGE OF THE
KINDERGARTEN THERE, STARTING A
FIRE AND THEN CRASHED ON THE
OTHER SIDE OF IT WHEN OUR TEAM
FIRST ARRIVED ON THE GROUND,
YOU COULD SEE A NUMBER OF
BODIES, COVERED IN GOLD FOIL,
THAT HAD BEEN RECOVERED.
BUT NOW THEY ARE SAYING ALL
NINE PEOPLE WHO WERE ON THAT
HELICOPTER, INCLUDING AS YOU
MENTIONED, THE MINISTER OF
INTERIOR, DENIS MONASTYRSKY,
THE DEPUTY MINISTRY, AND THREE
AT SECRETARY OF STATE, INTERIOR
MINISTRY, THEY WERE ALL KILLED
IMMEDIATELY UPON IMPACT.
NOW WE KNOW AS WELL, THAT THE
OTHER PEOPLE WHO WERE KILLED
WERE A NUMBER OF CHILDREN, AND
THEIR PARENTS.
PARENTS DROPPING THEIR KIDS OFF
AT SCHOOL, MAX.
YOU CAN IMAGINE, THIS IS EVERY
FAMILY'S WORST NIGHTMARE.
THE QUESTION BECOMES, HOW DID
THIS HAPPEN?
BECAUSE THIS HELICOPTER WAS
SOPHISTICATED, IT IS AN AIRBUS,
JUST UPDATED THE AVIONICS ON
IT.
SO WE DO NOT KNOW EXACTLY HOW
THIS HAPPENED.
WE KNOW THERE WAS A LOT OF FOG,
THAT VISIBILITY IN THE AREA.
SOME PEOPLE SAID THEY WERE ABLE
TO HEAR THE CRASH, BUT COULD
NOT IMMEDIATELY SEE IT, BECAUSE
THERE WAS SUCH POOR VISIBILITY.
UKRAINIAN AUTHORITIES SAY THEY
ARE INVESTIGATING EVERY
POSSIBLE AVENUE, AS TO HOW THIS
HAPPENED.
THERE IS NO SENSE AT THIS STATE
THAT THERE WAS FOUL PLAY
INVOLVED.
BUT OF COURSE, THEY DO NOT WANT
TO ELIMINATE ANY POSSIBILITY
EITHER.
RIGHT NOW, THE MAIN EFFORT
CONTINUES TO BE, AS YOU CAN SEE
BEHIND ME, YOU CAN SEE, IT IS
STILL SMOLDERING IN PARTS, THE
EFFORT TO GO THROUGH THAT
WRECKAGE OF A KINDERGARDEN AND
MAKE SURE THERE ARE NO OTHER
PEOPLE WHO WERE KILLED OR
INJURED, WHO HAVE BEEN
UNACCOUNTED FOR, AND TRY TO GET
TO THE BOTTOM OF EXACTLY WHAT
HAPPENED HERE MAX.
>> IT COULD WELL BE AN ACCIDENT,
COULDN'T IT?
NO SUGGESTION THERE WAS FOUL
PLAY INVOLVED HERE.
HOW DO YOU THINK PRESIDENT
ZELENSKYY --
>> NO SUGGESTED THERE IS FOUL
PLAY.
>> HOW DO YOU THINK PRESIDENT
ZELENSKYY --
>> AND I COULD JUST SAY, TO
UNDERSCORE --
YES, I MEAN, HE'S ALREADY COME
OUT AND SAID THIS IS A TRAGEDY.
IT IS A PROFOUND TRAGEDY.
A MEMBER OF HIS CABINET, THE
ENTIRE LEADERSHIP, ESSENTIALLY
OF THE INTERIOR MINISTRY.
BUT IT IS IMPORTANT TO
UNDERSCORE, AS YOU SAID, IT IS
NO SUGGESTION OF FOUL PLAY.
AND THE WEATHER HERE WAS
TERRIBLE THIS MORNING.
AND AS I SAID, A LOT OF PEOPLE
TALKING ABOUT HOW BAD
VISIBILITY WAS, HOW MUCH FOG
THERE WAS.
I AM GUESSING WE WILL LEARN
MORE IN THE COMING HOURS.
WE CONTINUE TO SEE PEOPLE
COMING HERE TO PAY THEIR
RESPECTS, TO LEAVE FLOWERS.
EARLIER ON, OUR TEAM WAS ON THE
GROUND AS THE WIFE OF THE
DEPUTY INTERIOR MINISTER CAIN
AND LOOKED AT THE BODY OF HER
HUSBAND.
YOU CAN OBVIOUSLY SEE HOW
CRUSHED AND DEEPLY UPSET SHE
WAS.
AND I THINK FOR EVERYBODY HERE,
THERE IS A SENSE THAT THIS IS A
TERRIBLE, AWFUL, SENSELESS
TRAGEDY AMIDST SO MUCH PAIN AND
HEARTBREAK AND DEVASTATION
ALREADY.
IT IS THE LAST THING UKRAINE
NEEDED.
AND NO EASY ANSWERS, AND NO
EASY PERSON TO BLAME IN THIS
SITUATION UNTIL WE GET A MUCH
BETTER SENSE OF HOW THIS
HAPPENED.
>> CLARISSA WARD ON THE SCENE
THERE IN BROVARY, THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.